peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voici donc le dernier roman de
romain gary les mangeurs d'étoilés il
paraît chez gallimard
les mangeurs des toiles c'est le nom
qu'on donne en amérique du sud et dans
les caraïbes aux indiens qui mange qui
mâche des plantes qui sont en réalité
des drogues et d'une façon générale dans
le livre de romain gary
les mangeurs des poils ont un sens un
peu plus large ce sont tous les gens
sont y poursuivre un rêve qui court
après une sorte de chimère ou a prévu
une idée et après une étoile nous sommes
tous plus ou moins des mangeurs des
toiles semble-t-il au sens de romain
gary
le livre est une sorte de tragi-comédie
le roman picaresque politique en ce sens
qu'il raconte l'histoire d'un dictateur
d'un de ces dictateurs comme il en
existe comme il en a existé depuis
trente ou quarante ans en particulier
dans les caraïbes le pays que décrit
romain gary ou les événements se
déroulent les faits se déroulaient est
un pays imaginaire qui n'est pas nommé
d'ailleurs mais ce pourrait être très
bien par exemple cuba de batista d'avant
castres on pourrait bien voler en
janvier ou peut-être même certains pays
menacent amérique centrale amérique
cendres du sud le héros du livre
s'appelle al maillot le général a le
maillot c'est un de ces dictateurs
sanglants comme il en existe comme il en
a existé et lui il est sanglant pour une
certaine raison que vous expliquer au
fond c'est tout le sens du livre il veut
faire un pacte avec le diable parce
qu'ils croient que c'est avec le diable
qu'il faut traiter pour avoir la
puissance et non pas avec dieu on a même
dit que je faisais de l'hérésie cathare
c'est en ville ou en réalité al maillot
est un indien qui a été élevé
dans la fois par les prêtres mais une
fois souvent propagée par les prêtres
très primitif et pas seulement par eux
que la terre appartient au diable le
ciel à partir d' adieu le diabète ou
puissant très puissant il peut tout
faire tout mal l'argent la sexualité les
femmes c'est le diable donc ce jeune
indien s'est dit bon d'être bien le plus
puissant sur la terre c'est le diable
effet rencontré le diable et faire un
pacte avec lui de toute puissance et c
est donc ce garçon commence à faire du
mal commencent à se vautrer dans lequel
les crimes les plus abjects abjecte dans
l'espoir de faire l'encontre du maître
de ce monde
il cherche ce qu'il peut faire de plus
abject pour cela dont le pot lui plaire
pour attirer son attention et bénéficier
de sa protection de la protection aux
100 espagnole du mot si vous voulez je
voulais un peu entre autres thèmes que
j'ai orchestré dans ce livre j'ai voulu
raconter la vérité sur la sphère fausses
j'ai dit elle selon vous guette n'a pas
dit toute la vérité même que goethe et a
franchement marty la véritable tragédie
de faust
ce n'est pas qu'il ait vendu son âme au
diable ce qu' il n'y a pas de diable
pour cela je vous ai acheté votre âme et
n'a jamais pu rencontré le diable n'a
jamais pu vendre sa marchandise est mort
désespérée c'est la tragédie de l'homme
par excellence dans la soirée de
l'absolu il n'y a pas preneur de ce
qu'il a à offrir et al maillot cherche
le diable il fait des actions de plus en
plus horribles disons je tracte quand
j'ai lu le roman dans le plus parfait
réalisme sans aucune
sans aucune contribution du fantastique
il est convaincu il n'est pas le seul
vous avez des prédicateurs américain
très connu est très célèbre qui passent
leur temps pour ne pas le nommer billy
graham qui passe son temps à dire que le
diable est une présence à l physique
vivent dans le monde qu'il faut se
méfier de nuit et bien écoutez et auprès
de certaines populations primitives
extrêmement superstitieuse
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient fait de
la propagande pour le diable parce que
si le diable le maître de ce nom il est
tellement dangereux s'il est tellement
puissant s'il peut tout donner car vous
crever de faim de maladie et de misère
on n'avait qu'une idée c'est de conclure
un pacte avec le diable puisque des gens
civilisés déjà aussi hautement placé
aussi spirituellement en riz au lait de
connaissances et de religion que le
renard graham par exemple vous affirme
que le diable et la bahia preneur peut
s'entendre avec lui surtout que vous
êtes en bas dans la misère et la
garderie
disons pour transposer les choses
politiquement puisqu'il ya quand même un
arrière plan politique dans votre livre
ça se passe dans les caraïbes et au fond
des problèmes abordés à travers ses
personnages car il s'agit d'un roman
bien sûr c'est le problème des rapports
très actuelle toujours les états unis
avec l'amérique du sud et les caraïbes
en particulier le même l'afrique je
voulus
lui rendre physique incarnée par des
personnages d'une manière extrêmement
presque pratique pragmatique les
rapports de l'amérique avec ce qu'on
appelle le tiers-monde où surtout plus
exactement avec les pats le tiers-monde
avec les pays profondément sous
développés je voulu montrer par
l'intermédiaire du personnage féminin de
la fille de ce livre dont les rapports
avec lille sont le dictateur romain où
j'ai voulu montrer comment une certaine
amérique propre idéaliste traîne a
marqué par la naïveté j'ai dû bien une
certaine année amérique il faut que moi
quand même pas dire d'abord que
l'amérique est naïve et ensuite pas dire
qu'elle est toujours propre auquel est
toujours salle
c'est une certaine amérique idéaliste
extrêmement bien disposés à vers ces
pays de se développer avec ces gens à
provoquent des catastrophes absolument
épouvantable par son idéalisme le
personnage de la fille j'ai voulu
incarner je le dis carrément je suis
passé j'ai réussi dans un personnage
vivant perceptible à physique
cette amérique là d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
donné de nom à la mairie de kennedy
c'est là oui d'ailleurs cette fille est
obsédé par kennedy est la nouvelle
frontière cette idée de la nouvelle
frontière de kennedy qui se situe
partout dans le monde est une frontière
abstraite de l'idéalisme où l'on peut
aller pour faire du bien dans cette
recherche du mal que fait elle maillot
le dictateur il a un modèle un modèle
qui semble obséder vous avez connu
beaucoup d'hommes politiques ou non de
le seo mal garé dans les caraïbes et
ailleurs en amérique du sud et en
afrique
il est obsédé par hitler et ils
s'informent sur tout ce qui concerne la
vie d'hitler les gens qui entourent
hitler sans rêve c'est de s'entourer
lui-même de gens qui t'entourent hitler
ya même d'aider les imposteurs parce que
des gens qui exploitent cet argent doit
régler avec ce je crois que vous avez
connu des deux côtés d'abord je veux
dire quelque chose par exemple un fait
historique connue lorsque khroma
a été renversé au ghana et qu'on a
soulevé la pierre en sont sortis des
personnages qui était auprès d'hitler un
arrache l'aviatrice qui a été la
dernière à quitter le bon qu'hier le
docteur schneider je crois si je m'abuse
je ne suis pas sûr du nord mais qui
était en tout cas l'adjoint de l'infâme
docteur mal délais dans les camps
d'extermination et d'autres encore ces
gens là
recueillez les proche d'hitler par une
espèce de fétichisme parce que pour eux
quand même hitler représentent une
puissance extraordinaire
il ya des gens qui sont obsédés par
hitler est d'abord je dirais même qu
hitler pour moi tombe dans le cadre de
mon roman c'était un homme qui croyait
au mal à la force brute puissante et
aveugle et si vous voulez ne pensez pas
clairement mais dans son subconscient
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient croyant
l'absolu du mal et de la puissance il
cherchait à conclure un pacte avec le
diable ça lui est tombé sur la gueule on
ne peut pas y a pas preneur que vous
soyez hitler ou n'importe quelle
personne ne vient pas dans votre camelot
vous payer pour ça alors autant ne pas
tuer massacrer
ça ne sert pas on fait pas le contact
rencontre des tas de marula d'imposteur
de films east qui vous disent c'est moi
c'est moi on fait des millions de morts
mais en réalité il n'y a pas preneur on
peut pas conclure le marché l'absolu
hauteur de porte votre dictateur a le
maillot ne collectionne pas seulement et
les collaborateurs big l'aiea les
mauvaises actions
il est très observé aussi par les
saltimbanques maison par les jongleurs
partout les gens du du music hall et
s'est rallongée riche et interbox et ses
artistes de l'impossible humain sur le
plan physique qui cherche à réaliser
parce qu'un des thèmes du livre qui est
d'ailleurs jouer al mayakhi région et
hitler qui rejoint les dictateurs en
général et cette aspiration à la
toute-puissance de l'individu de l'être
humain qui voudraient accéder à une
puissance extraordinaire et briser les
records de puissants jamais à tabriz et
les lois les lois ne lui réviser les
lois gallaher de la tigresse de l'homme
et cela cherche à le briser dans le
domaine de l' équilibre de l'acrobatie
et notamment les jongleurs jeu
plus grand angle heures des temps
modernes rester lydie ton amour
désespéré parce qu'il n'arrivait plus à
se surpasser
je voulais utiliser comiquement j'avoue
c'est le plus grand virtuose par exemple
de mormant ce monsieur m'a nommé ce
cookie astra duo russe et ses tables son
acte sont consiste à jouer du bach
debout sur la tête
ce numéro a existé tout moment ils
cherchent à se surpasser joue le
transposer je voulais un carnet dans ses
personnages et signifié l'impossibilité
sur le même thème de sortir de loi de la
nature l'impossibilité du surhumain
j'ai caricature et à travers eux aussi
bien moi même artiste qui aspirent au
chef-d'oeuvre que faust qui aspirent à
l'éternité à la vie éternelle à la
jeunesse que tout ce dictateur ou autres
qui espère pouvoir s'élever au dessus
des lois de la nature et de la condition
humaine
ce sont des certainement et bien je vous
remercie je rappelle le titre de ce
livre ce roman de romain gary que ras
une suite d'ailleurs encore une question
à vous poser car il est annoncé comme
faisant partie du nouveau média local le
premier volet ou d'un comédien américain
le deuxième s'appellera adieu gary
cooper dans laquelle je montre
l'amérique disant adieu aux airs
tranquilles plein de certitudes deux
sortants et rencontrant le temps
d'angoise merci romain gary s'appelle le
titre donc de ce livre les mangeurs des
toiles de romain gary
chez gallimard
[Musique]